LEAFS.
AND GOT
THROUGH.
GREAT PUCK, IT IS A BACKHAND ,
IT OVER THE TOP OF THE NEOV.
LEFT SIDE PASS.
PLAY MADE BY  --
ON THE LIGHTNING.
ALEX KILLORN WITH THE E PICK ON
THE SHOT BY CERNAK.
NOT ABLEWITH THE SAID, HE
CRUISES IT BEHIND THE NET, WRAP
AROUND.
THE REBOUND PLAY STUFF , HEDMAN
HAS TERRIFIC SPEED, THE REACH,
THE BY  TRAIN I,
THE 13 GAMES, A TERRIFIC
FEED FROM NICK PAUL.
IT IS 2-0,
IS NOTHING COMPLICATED, PUT
PRESSURE ON MORGAN RIELLY, ABLE
NOW THE ALL-
TIME POINT LEADER IN TAMPA BAY
FOR STEVEN STAMKOS.
HE PI
4-0, LIGHTNING.
KUCHEROV FINDS IT.  ABLE TO GET
PUCK TO THE MOVING
IN, BLACKWELL, BLACK FELL BACK
TO THE GAS AND LET THE
VETERANS TAKE OVER PICK
>> ANOTHER GOAL IS ADDED FROM
HIM HERE.
GETS TO THE POINT, FINDS A WAY
>> HE HID BEHIND VASILEVSKY
PIXMA GOOD CHANCEBELONGS TO
ANOTHER POINT FOR FOR, THE
THIRD POWER PLAY GOAL OF THE
GAMEME
QUICKLY ONE TOUCHES IT.
NONOIN SHORTHANDED.
HOLD ONTO IT, AND EVENTUALLY
WIN THE PUCK AGTHE BRIEF
FIVE ON THREE.
SHORT SIDE, IT AND THE
EXTENSION.
THE PUCK GOES OFF THE POST AND
OFF TORONTO,
SHOTS AND SCORES, BEAUTIFULLY
EXECUTED.
HERE TO RECOGNIZE THE PUCK  --
SEASON-THE HIGH END GOALS
SCORED AND ALLOWED FOR TAMPA
BAY, AND TORONTO REREKALLGREN
LATE GETTING ACROSS.
YOU CAN SEE HOW LATE HE IS